ils vont au resto ils veulent pas payer
ils s'achètent un t-shirt soit ils
veulent un t-shirt il le paye pas vous
trouvez que c'est normal excusez-moi il
y a plein d'animateurs qui font pareil
je suis pas quelqu'un de jaloux mais ça
me met mal à l'aise que quelqu'un qui
n'est rien foutu de sa vie qui soit
passé une fois dans la villa des cœur
brisés 50000 € par mois gagne le salaire
d'un grand patron ou 10 fois ou 20 fois
quelqu'un se fait chier à se lever tous
les matins une infirmière
je suis désolé c'est pas un métier en
plus le pire c'est que aujourd'hui c'est
un modèle de réussite les gamins
aujourd'hui ils veulent plus être
acteurs ils veulent plus être
footballeur il va être influenceurs
mon fils